NOAH FALSTEIN: Hello, everybody.
Welcome.
So this is our Growing
Games at Google session.
I'm glad to see so
many people here
who are interested in games.
I'm Noah Falstein.
I'm our Chief Game
Designer here at Google.
I'm also a member of the
Scalable Developer Advocacy
Group.
I'm here today to
give you a big picture
of just some of the
many ways that Google
supports game development.
And also, we have a
couple of my colleagues
here to go a little
bit more into depth
in some of the areas where we
have some new developments.
And I'll try to touch on some
of the stuff that was also
covered at the keynote here
at which I will be ad libbing.
So forgive me.
For those of you who
are coming to see Duncan
Curtis because
you're Duncan's fans,
he's chickened out
for the measly excuse
that at any moment he
be called away to attend
the birth of his first baby.
But what the hell.
We still love you Duncan.
So how many of you
are game developers?
Professional?
Wow.
That's great.
Looks like more
than half the room.
And I take it most
of the rest of you
are probably game players?
OK.
Well, you're in the right place.
Let's get going.
I've been a professional
game developer since 1980.
And in all that time,
I've only seen really
one constant in this industry.
And that's been the change that
it goes through so quickly.
So we've grown from this
tiny little hobbyist
market where we were putting
floppy disks in Ziploc bags
with printed out
pages of instructions
to this huge industry where it
touches on almost everybody who
uses information technology.
It's just been amazing to
see the growth over time.
And really, there's no
sign of it slowing down.
I've never, in fact, seen as
much promise in the industry
is there is right now.
If you just think
about everything
that's going on with consoles,
mobile, web, new growth areas
like wearables and VR,
everything is thriving.
And we're supporting all
those things here at Google.
But any support
system for something
as complex and multifaceted as
the games industry has become
can be a little bit
hard to picture.
You've got a lot
of things plugging
into other things and things
that depend on other things.
So describing what
we do here at Google
is similarly complex at times.
We've got hardware, operating
systems, software packages,
and services to
describe that all
interconnect in all these ways.
But the nice thing is that
we in the games industry
have a long history
of having to describe
these kind of complex things.
You think about build trees
or technology trees, skills
or magic abilities
that are associated
with different character
classes, it's the kind of thing
that we do all
the time in games.
So if you'll excuse me
for going a bit meta,
let me talk about applying
that analogy here to Google.
I think it's really,
generally, pretty appropriate
because, as game developers,
we're all really on quests
in the work that we do.
We're trying to build
the game, and in the way,
we have battles with bugs--
sometimes giant bugs--
and deadline dragons.
We're all after that fabled
golden chest of loot at the end
and want to survive to be
able to launch our next quest
and keep going.
So think of Google as supplying
the equipment, the armor
to level up your skills.
And whether you're just a
level seven coder, looking
for a new API to arm
yourself, or maybe
you're a level 20 game
producer and you're
trying to map your
path to the fabled land
of mobile engagement.
Maybe you're a
demi-CEO and you're
in search of a
monetization spell.
We can help you here.
So this is a rather
schematic skill tree.
Unlike games, where one thing
directly depends on another,
it's a bit more
complex here at Google.
So I'm keeping it simple.
But if you picture the operating
systems and the hardware
platforms that run your games
as your choice of a character
faction or a hero a class,
and the services that we
offer as skills, or
spells, or power ups,
you'll find it easier to
see which ones of those
apply to you, and your games,
and your game development,
and be able to mix and
match as you go along.
So let me go through
some of these.
For each of these
services as power ups,
I'm going to be
showing cards here
that will talk about
aspects of game development
they help, whether it's
building your game,
growing your audience,
engaging that audience,
or monetizing the game.
So let's start with
the operating systems.
The Android OS.
We give you the API libraries
and the software tools
necessary to build, test,
and debug your game.
And Android's reach
is just enormous.
Every day, over a million new
Android devices are activated.
With Chrome, you can
build cutting edge games
for the web that use tools
to make it scalable and easy
to deploy, able to run
on multiple platforms.
And the Chrome Web Store
helps the interested users
to find your games.
And then we have all the devices
that these games can run on.
Android phones and tablets are
the largest potential platform
for games worldwide, with
over a billion installations.
Just think about a
billion installations out
there will be seeing games
with a billion players
at some point in the future.
Last year, we
announced Android Wear.
You can include
wearables, like watches,
as part of your game's
notification system.
Or as we saw with some
of the great new things
going on at the keynote,
watches themselves are really
an interesting,
standalone device
to consider running games on.
There's just so much you
can do with them now.
And also to go to a bigger
screen, we have Android TV.
You can engage players with a
variety of hardware solutions
there.
It's out on a lot of
televisions that are coming out
in the very near future.
And now, we also are adding
games built for Chromecast
to join Android's
living room story.
More detail on a moment from
Nathan here about Cast games.
Google cardboard was featured
quite a bit at the keynote
and very exciting.
I really think that
this as an area
that we're going to see a lot
of growth in in the near future.
It's our inexpensive VR solution
announced just last year
at I/O. And now as you've heard,
we have over a million units
already in the
hands of the public.
And think about that kind
of blue ocean out there.
If you're a small
game developer,
and you want to
create something that
goes out to over a
million potential users
and is inexpensive
to develop for,
cardboard is a great
choice for you.
So you should check out
their talks and their display
here at Moscone
for more updates.
They've got some great
stuff that they're showing.
And developers
have already begun
to explore new terrain with
our Project Tango devices.
They use a human scale
awareness of their surroundings
to engage players with
entirely new types of games.
How many have you have been over
in the Project Tango section
and seen some of the
games they're doing?
Well, I hope that all of
you get a chance to catch it
by tomorrow because they've
got some wonderful games
and non-game apps.
But Tango is really
going to shine
for a lot of entertainment
applications there.
So those operating systems
running on our hardware
platforms can support a really
wide variety of services.
And they're, as I said,
the equivalent of power ups
to provide that kind of
enchanting Google magic you
want to put in your games.
So for example, we've
got Google Play.
The Google Play Store--
every month, Android users
download more than 1.5
billion apps and games.
And the user ratings and
rankings on the Play Store
can generate buzz to
engage your users.
You can place ads for your
game right in the Play Store.
And you can sell your
apps in over 190 countries
and territories worldwide.
So tremendous reach there.
And to go along with
that, Play Games Services
is a really versatile
package we have that
helps you build better games.
Just some of the
things it can do
include achievements,
leaderboards, Cloud Save.
It's got real time multiplayer
and quests for your mobie--
and that's Android,
or iOS, and web games.
And it lets you track specific
game events so that you
can analyze micro-gameplay
and patterns
and tune your game very well.
So as a designer, I find that
particularly interesting.
You can get down to a very
deep level with what Play Games
Services provides for you.
And a lot of that stuff is
very powerful and easy to use.
Play Games has grown
to 450 million users
since we launched it
at I/O two years ago,
with 185 million users added
in just the past six months.
And it's the fastest growing
mobile gaming platform
in history.
We'll be hearing a lot
more about this from Ben
in a few minutes.
But until then, let's move on.
I mentioned Google
Cloud Services.
It enables developers to build,
test, and deploy applications
on our highly scalable and
reliable infrastructure.
You can choose from
computing, storage,
and applications services
for your web, mobile,
and back-end
solutions with cloud.
Then Google Analytics.
The best way to
grow your audiences
is really to know who's playing
your game and on what devices
and where they come from.
So with Analytics, you
can help your designers
identify bottlenecks in
flow and improve gameplay.
And the next few
power up services
specifically focus on
increasing your bottom line.
For example, AdMob and
the Google Display Network
that can extend
your reach can help
you place ads in mobile
apps and on sites
across the web to more users.
You can earn revenue with
advertising from over a million
Google advertisers, or
grow your in-app purchasing
by bringing your
best users back.
And DoubleClick.
It's another chance to let you
take your in-game advertising
to the next level, across all
the screens with ad management
tools.
You can integrate
with top ad networks
to maximize revenue and
create a gamer friendly ad
experience with things like the
TrueView skippable video ads
that give a better ad
experience for the gamers,
and also that means higher
monetization for you
because they're having more
fun and not as frustrated.
Advertising with
AdWords allows you
to reach new players
at the precise moment
that they're searching
for your games.
And last, but
definitely not least,
we've got YouTube that satisfies
gamers' hunger for video.
You've got 95% of
gamers who turn
to YouTube for entertainment
and information in the moments
that matter to them.
And you can drive engagement,
grow your player base
with YouTube by allowing
players to easily upload
and share their
game capture videos.
So that's it for now.
We're adding more
services all the time.
And I really haven't even
hit everything in depth.
We offer a really
thorough and varied set
of platforms and services that
can help build your games,
grow your audience, engage
them with these great features,
and monetize your content.
So here's a link,
developer.google.com/games,
that gives you more information
on how you can start to play
with these power ups and win
at this meta-game of game
development.
And now I'm not going
to test your patience
by going into depth in
each of these things
or testing you on what I've
just been talking about,
but we are going
to tell you more
about two very specific areas.
We're going to start
with the Nathan Camarillo
here from the Google Cast team.
He's going to tell you
about the new services
available to developers
from Google Cast.
Nathan.
[APPLAUSE]
NATHAN CAMARILLO: Thanks Noah.
Hi, everybody.
And Hello, everybody on the
internet that's watching.
I'm here today to talk you guys.
Modern mobile devices are
amazing tools for gaming.
They give you this great
experience right on the screen.
And they have a ton
of sensors to capture
your touch and gestures to
enhance your gaming experience.
With all this technology
that you have,
wouldn't it be great
if you could just
experience the fun of playing
a game in the same room
as your friends?
With Google Cast games, you
can recapture that magic
of sitting down in
your house and playing
a game in the same
room as your friends,
all on your own devices
connected to a really
big screen with great audio.
My name is Nathan
Camarillo, a Product Manager
on the Google Cast team.
And today, I want to tell you
more about these technologies
and some of the great
improvements our team has
made recently to enable new
experiences in the living room.
Goog Cast is designed to
use your mobile device
to drive experiences on
home entertainment devices.
For example, we see a 45%
increase in YouTube watch time
upon a Chromecast activation.
And Chromecast is
really easy to use.
You just pick the content
using the apps you already
know and love, you
tap the Cast button,
and you enjoy the
content on your TV.
It's pretty easy.
Our first product
was the Chromecast,
which has sold over
17 million units,
and was the top selling
streaming device, including
streaming boxes, in 2014.
We're building a larger
ecosystem of devices,
from televisions
to set-top boxes
and streaming devices for audio.
This year, we rolled out
audio devices powered
by Google Cast for audio.
And Chromecast continues
to see tremendous success.
Here at I/O 2015,
we'll show you how
we're improving
the Cast experience
by unlocking even more
opportunities for game
developers.
And what does that mean for
you as a game developer?
Across Google Cast,
when games and apps
are connected to the TV, we see
increased engagement, stronger
monetization, and
because the living room
is inherently social, you have
multiplayer games that result
in more downloads for you.
Because you can utilize the
power of a mobile device,
all the power of that
platform, like payments,
already exist and
are available to you.
Just a few months
ago, in November 2014,
we released our first wave
of games for Google Cast.
These games are really
fun, and we worked closely
with some great partners
to make those games happen.
Some of those partners
are here today,
which I'm very happy about.
I want to take a little bit of
time to talk about these games
because they're really
great examples of how
to design a Cast game, in case
you didn't get to try them
yourself.
If you played any of these
games, especially Just Dance
Now by Ubisoft,
I've expect you've
got some good moves by now.
As for the Cast team,
well-- as a group
we're better at dancing than
we were a few months ago.
But this is a game that really
uses your mobile devices
sensors to detect
how you're moving,
or whether you're just standing
there and pumping your fist,
or you're like really
getting involved
in using your whole body.
Classic family fun
is also a great theme
for Google Cast games.
That's why we worked
closely with Hasbro
to bring adaptations of some
of your favorite board games
to the big screen.
If dancing isn't your
thing, maybe SCRABBLE Blitz
is more your speed.
It's fast.
It's intense.
And guess what, you actually
have to spell things.
There's no AutoCorrect
here to help you out.
We also have other
classic brands
like CONNECT 4 Quads, Monopoly
Dash, and SIMON Swipe.
You should check out some
of these great games.
They really are
fun for all ages.
And game shows are
really fun too, right?
You guys like game shows.
If you think about it,
almost every great game show
has some sort of big
board full of fun
and prizes and surprises.
When we worked with
Sony Pictures Television
on Wheel of Fortune,
we saw how much fun
that could be to use
your TV as the big board
while controlling the game
with your mobile device.
By using a game show
format for your design,
you too can play at home.
You might not win a
giant bundle of cash
or win a lifetime
supply of shaving cream,
but you will have a lot of fun.
We also had developers
making games on their own
and publishing them
to Google Play.
It's really that
easy to make a game.
We noticed a game called Emoji
Party for Chromecast by Troido
And we reached out to them
and worked with them directly
to fully utilize
the Cast experience.
It's a fun game where these
movie titles pop up on the TV.
And they're all
encoded in Emoji speak.
You compete with your friends
to see who can guess them
first and earn the most points.
And in this game in
particular, ten players
are connected at the same
time through one television.
Can anybody guess
what this one is?
Yeah, okay.
This is a easy one.
Planet of the Apes.
These types of
games go a long way
toward fulfilling a
dream for game developers
to enable people to
play games on their TVs
without expensive game consoles.
These games are great for
Cast-- all these ones I just
talked about.
They're social, they utilize
the phones and tablets
people already love
using, and they're
surprising in the fun way
that they achieve game play
with simple, accessible design.
If you're interested in learning
more about the core concepts
and principles of designing
great games for Google Cast,
check out the talk
that I'm giving called
Designing Games for Google
Cast here at I/O tomorrow
at 9:00 AM in alcove two.
And all the games
I just discussed
were made using the Google
Cast SDK we released last year.
They use a model we call
a Receiver Cast Game.
An app running on the sender,
which is your mobile device,
connects to a
receiver device, which
is any device like a
Chromecast, and passes along
the information the
receiver needs to load
the game from the cloud.
In a typical
Chromecast application,
like a video on demand app, this
is a really simple transaction.
But when you make
a game, there's
a lot of interaction
that's going on.
And it's going to happen
between multiple devices or web
browsers.
During our partnership with
the titles I mentioned earlier,
we found one big
way that we could
and help to improve
the game development
experience for developers.
That's why here at I/O, we're
announcing the game manager
APIs for Google Cast.
The game manager APIs
make it faster and easier
for game developers,
like yourself,
to Cast-enable their apps across
all the devices we support,
which is Android, iOS,
and Chrome browsers,
and get those devices connected
to a Chromecast or Android TV.
All the synchronization
between players
is handled through
the Cast receiver,
which is the Chromecast.
It acts like a
server for the match,
and will store all
the game state,
and take the role of pushing
notifications to the devices
when new information
is available.
We're excited to see what
kind of innovative games
you'll create and build
using the game manager
APIs for Google Cast.
And now it's even faster and
easier than it was before.
If you want to
hear more details,
check out the box talks we
have going on tomorrow called
Game Manager APIs for Google
Cast, where our engineers will
walk you through the
implementation of Google Cast
Managers APIs.
Also be sure to check
out our sandbox booth
on the third floor to check
out demos of the games I just
mentioned and some other ones
that we have in development,
Catch Phrase by Hasbro and
Tricky Titans by MediaMonks.
In Catch Phrase,
the classic game
comes to Cast as two player
stand in front of the screen
and everyone in the room can
see the catch phrase on the TV.
I don't know if you saw us
playing this earlier today.
Everyone goes crazy shouting
clues at the guessers
and points are
scored by pressing
a button on the mobile device.
You can expect this
one to be fun and loud.
So please come play
it with us upstairs.
MediaMonks created
a fun game called
Tricky Titan with great visuals
and strategic turn based
game play.
These giant titans are
sitting on top of villages
and they use large shovels
to scoop up houses and people
and throw them at each other.
It's really clever.
Both games are in development
and are using the Game Manager
APIs already.
Now you might be
asking yourself,
we have this giant
TV, a Chromecast,
and an amazing
computer in our pocket.
Couldn't we do a
little bit more?
Well, of course we can.
That's why we created the Remote
Display APIs for Google Cast.
There are millions of mobile
devices with powerful GPUs
and sensors ready to send
amazing interactive content
to the largest
screen in the home.
With the Remote Display
APIs for Google Cast,
this is now possible.
Remote Display for
Android and iOS
allows app developers
to take full advantage
of the multiscreen
Google Cast model.
This is really important
and it supports
one of our key principles
of cross platform
compatibility for Google Cast.
Whether you and your friends
own an Android device or an iOS
device and they come
over to your house,
you can all play
together and have fun.
So integrating
Remote Display means
you can harness all of those
increasingly powerful CPUs
and GPUs in your phone and
build dual display games
were you use the phone to
render both a local display
and a virtual one.
And we handle sending the
virtual display directly
to the large screen
via our Cast protocol.
As a developer, that means
bigger games, more screens,
and more fun.
With a remote display,
you trigger the experience
directly from within
your game or app.
It follows the
same simple model I
discussed earlier of all our
Google Cast interactions.
Just tap the Cast button and go.
It increases the
discoverability of the feature
and it's a big
difference compared
to competing technologies.
You don't have to rely on the
player to exit the app or game
and turn on some
system level feature.
They can have the experience
you intended them to have.
For example, in Ubisoft's
racing game, Driver Speedboat
Paradise, you can blast
through dangerous waves
and jump off ramps to
fly through the air
and perform impressive stunts.
The team uses cutting edge 3D
graphics, Triple A effects,
and HD textures on a mobile
device sent across the room
to your screen.
And speedboat racing
is a lot of fun,
but maybe you'd like
a nice game of tennis.
Rolocule has this
fun casual tennis
game called Motion Tennis.
You hold the phone in
your hand like a tennis
racquet and swing your arm
to choose the type of shot
to make next.
It's fun, intuitive, and
great for multiple players,
but you need to hold
on to your phone tight.
If you're an inventor,
you might want
to consider making some
really cool phone strap
technology or something
because in the coming years,
I think the screen
repair guys are going
to love this remote display
technology as things
fly across the room.
And we've all heard
the phrase, when
pigs fly, and for many
of us, myself included,
that's especially true
about going to the gym.
Now with Fitflap!
by BreakFirst,
you can play games
and get fit at the same time.
And this really works.
I was in some pain
from testing this game.
The game is really
cool because it
uses image recognition
and the front
facing camera on the
phone to control the pig.
You really flap your
arms and make the pig fly
and collect coins while
dodging obstacles.
And I could tell you everybody
at the office had fun laughing
at me when I demoed this
to them for the first time.
And you really have to get your
pig, which is me, in shape.
So in between flights, you
can go dance with your pig
or run in place while your
pig runs on the treadmill.
And just like these games,
your real creative genius
shows itself when you combine
great social multiplayer
with the power of mobile
devices and the big screen.
Come check these games out on
the third floor in the Google
Cast area.
You can create new games or
even extend your existing games
and applications with the
Google Cast Remote Display APIs.
When you do it all right, you
have an entirely new living
room experience
and players really
get involved in the game.
We've seen this happen with
several great Cast games
already.
And we want yours to be next.
So visit
developers.google.com/cast
to learn more as we roll this
out on all platforms over
the next few days.
Be sure to check out our three
sequential box talks, which
will be repeated
two times tomorrow
called Designing
Games For Google Cast,
Game Manager APIs
for Google Cast,
and Google Cast Remote
Display for Games
starting at 9:00 and 3:00
PM tomorrow in alcove two
on the second floor.
On our developer
site, we're going
to provide you with
the receiver SDKs,
the sender SDKs for
Android, iOS, and Chrome,
sample games that help you get
started, game debugger apps
and debug UI for the receiver,
UX guidelines for Cast games,
and all the SDK
documentation and reference.
So we really want
to help you out.
Make sure to check out all the
demos that I mentioned before
because there's so many
unexplored games just waiting
to be created to inspire and
excite millions of gamers.
After I/O, please go
make something awesome.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
NOAH FALSTEIN: Thanks
very much Nathan.
And next up is Ben Frenkel
from Play Games Services
to tell you what's
new in that area.
BENJAMIN FRENKEL:
Thank you Noah.
So I'm Ben Frenkel, Product
Manager on the Play Games team.
And my focus is on
developer experiences.
And I'm going to cover three
exciting topics for you
in the next 15 minutes.
So first of all, I want to cover
the mission of the Play Games
Services team.
Two, what services we
provide developers.
And three, the impact
of those services.
And to help you better
understand the Play Games
mission, I want to start with
the story of Eric Froemling.
Eric is, in fact, here
today in the audience.
And I will embarrass him by
pointing him out over here.
So just wave to the crowd, Eric.
And Eric is the archetype
of the type of developer
we want to help with
Play Games Services.
He's a one man army that
does literally everything
for his game BombSquad.
And like all great
game developers,
Eric has a passion for making
awesome player experiences.
That's what is gift is.
But to turn that passion into
a sustainable, successful
business, he needs to
think about BombSquad
as an ongoing service
he delivers to players.
And when we look for inspiration
from the large, successful
developers who already manage
their game as a service--
well, in addition to
making awesome games, which
is a prerequisite to
any type of success,
we observe they do five
things exceptionally well.
They have cost efficient
ways to acquire players.
They think of their business
as a day to day battle.
And they rigorously set
and manage their business
to daily revenue targets.
They're advanced
users of analytics
that help them identify hotspots
in their business metrics
so they know what
to focus on, what
metrics they need to improve.
And they have a
deep understanding
of what's working and not
working for their players.
And almost without exception,
large, successful developers
who manage their
game as a service
have made major
investments in tools
that allow them to dynamically
make changes to their game
and deliver new
content to players.
And large studios will
have an army of people
to support each of
these functions.
So here's an example.
They'll have large
teams of developers
to focus on game
development, obviously,
data scientists to work in
analytics, live operation
support teams, marketing and
UA specialists, and so on.
So our mission is
to bridge the gap
between what the large studios
can do with an army behind them
and what the Erics of the world
can do, possibly just a one man
army.
And we've made significant
investments and progress
towards this goal.
Today, Play provide
services across the board,
from pre-registration, which
I'll talk about in a bit,
to help with user acquisition
to business management
tools in the developer
console, like Player Analytics,
to our suite of
core game services,
like quests, and achievements,
and leaderboards,
and multiplayer to keep players
engaged with new contents
and goals.
And these services have had
a major impact on developers.
And today, I'll just go
through a couple of examples
to show you.
So let's start with
Player Analytics.
It's a set of reports
in the developer console
that we launched at GDC
earlier in the year.
And throughout the development
of Player Analytics,
we worked very
closely with Eric,
the developer of BombSquad,
who I mentioned earlier.
And as we integrated over
different prototypes,
we discovered we needed
a deeper understanding
of BombSquad's in-game economy.
So we developed something called
the Sources and Sinks Report.
The Sources and
Sinks Report helps
developers understand
the relationship
between the rate at which
players earn a premium
currency, like gold coins,
or emeralds, or tickets
in Eric's case, and the rate
at which players consume that.
In an ideal world,
the rate at which
a player earns currency and
consumes currency roughly
nets out to zero.
And when we shared
this report with Eric,
he discovered that he
was giving away tickets
at a higher rate than
people could consume them.
And with that
information in hand,
he identified a
number of changes
that would bring his game
economy back into balance.
And after he made those
changes, the impact
could be seen almost immediately
in the Sources and Sinks
Report, which you can see here.
The ratios flipped.
And a few weeks later, average
revenue per daily active user
more than doubled.
And average revenue per paying
user grew by almost 70%.
That's almost unheard of impact
in such a short period of time.
And in Eric's own
words, "Player Analytics
has helped me home in on
BombSquad's shortcomings, right
the ship, and get to a point
where I can financially
justify making the
games I want to make."
And what we launched at
GCD is just the start.
We're going to
continue to invest
with new reports, new players
segments, new metrics,
new event types to make Player
Analytics even more powerful
for developers.
But we all know that
insights by themselves
don't move the needle
for your games.
You actually need to be able
to make updates to your game
to improving engagement,
retention, and monetization.
And that's why we
launched Quest last year,
which provides developers a
way to dynamically deliver
new content to players without
requiring those players
to update their games.
And that brings us
to our second case
study about concrete software.
In fact, we have another
special guest here today,
Keith from Concrete Software.
Wave your hand everybody.
Also a round of
applause for Keith.
And Concrete software
is another great example
of the type of developer we
want to support with Play Games
Services.
They've been making mobile
games for over a decade,
and they've seen great success.
But they're still
a small company.
And every minute they spend on
server infrastructure, server
side code, hosting,
and maintenance
is a minute they could
be spending on the things
that they are most passionate
about, which is making games.
And that's where Games
Services comes in--
and Quest in particular.
And Concrete has an
exemplary implementation
of Quest in their flagship
title, PBA Bowling they
follow all of our best practices
to a t to great effect.
And they've made
Quest an integral part
of their live
operation strategy.
And to help you understand
the degree to which they've
incorporated quests in to
their day to day operations,
I'd like to show
you and walk you
through the calendar promotions
from earlier in the year.
So as you can see here,
Concrete launches new content
multiple times a week
to keep players engaged.
And Quest played a critical
role in each of these launches.
For example, on January 7
here, a new bowling ball,
the Hammer Black
Widow Legend, which
is a very impressive, possibly
even scary bowling ball,
was launched.
And along with the ball,
they ran an ad in the game,
they promoted it
through social media,
they pushed notifications,
and, very importantly,
they had a Quest to support
the launch of the new content
as well.
And the reason why they've made
Quest such an integral part
of their live
operation strategy is
because Quest produced a
measurable, material impact
on player engagement.
They found users, on the
day that they accepted
a Quest, played close
to 15% more sessions,
and that the impact was sticky.
And they observed close to 4%
more sessions in the following
days.
And Quests are just the
start of our live operation
strategy on the Play
Games Services team.
We're going to
continue to invest
in tools that support dynamic
content updates, to make
your game feel more
alive and engaging,
tools to allow you to respond
to changing player needs,
and tools that allow you
to create more personalized
and fun user experiences
tailored to every player.
And everything I
just mentioned is
available for free to anybody
that integrates Games Services.
Finally, making
a successful game
is still really,
really hard to do.
It's a lot of work.
No doubt about it.
But with services like
Player Analytics and Quest,
integrating Play Games
Services is a great first step
to success.
So to learn more
about Games Services,
you go to our-- I won't touch
that microphone anymore.
You can go to out
developer site.
And on our developer
site, you can find out
SDKs for Android, iOS.
We have a cross platform
C plus SDK as well.
We have a Unity plug-in.
So whatever tool
you use, you'll be
able to integrate
Play Games Services.
We have samples, best practices
guidelines, more case studies,
and all the SDK
documentation references
you could ever possibly want.
So now I'm going to switch
gears and talk about something
called pre-registration.
This is what Duncan was
supposed to talk about.
But I will be
talking about it now.
And I will do it in
an Australian accent.
No, no I will not-- because
Duncan is Australian.
It has a back story there.
So whether we talk to
developers, large or small,
user acquisition is
really, really hard.
And doing it well is considered
essential to success.
And generating day
one buzz for your game
is in turn critical to a
successful user acquisition
strategy.
And that's where
pre-registration comes in.
It's a system that
allows players
to sign up to be notified
when a game is available.
It's a powerful user
acquisition tool
that allows developers to
create large day one releases.
And in markets like
Japan and Korea
that pioneered this
practice, we've
scene pre-registration result
in millions of day one users
of the game, instantly
bootstrapping
the game's ecosystem,
it's community,
and providing a huge boost
to store rankings right out
of the gate.
And here is how
pre-registration works.
So players will be driven
to a marketing landing
page of some sort.
For example, game
developer, Glu,
has created this landing page.
And for their upcoming game,
Terminator Genesys Revolution,
which is based on the
movie of the same title.
I think there's old Arnold
in it, and new Arnold,
and robot Arnold, and all
the types of Arnold's you
could want.
But the game is
not available yet.
So the call to action
here is to pre-register.
And from here, I would tap
on this pre-registration link
and be taken to the
Play Store listing.
There, I will see a gorgeous
pre-registration page,
where I can pre-register.
And once I've clicked on
the pre-register button,
I'm informed that I will
get a notification the day
that Terminator
Genesys launches.
I cannot wait.
And now that I'm
pre-registered I
can explore other
content about the game.
I can watch a YouTube video.
I can read more
about the details
of the back story of the game.
And as I scroll
down the page, I see
that I can share the
game with others,
and see other games
from Glu, in this case.
I can also see that if I install
the game by June 4-- next week,
I think-- I get a very welcoming
welcome package that includes
grenades, and rocket
launchers, and so on-- exactly
the types of things
that I think about when
I think of welcoming.
At last, it's launch day.
The game is ready to play.
I get a notification
on my device.
And when I tap it, I'm taken
to the game details page.
And from there, I can install
the game, get my reward,
my bounty of weapons, and
of course, very importantly,
save humanity from a never
ending wave of killer robots.
That's victory.
So what's next?
If you're interested in
using pre-registration
for an upcoming
game or an app, you
can contact your
BD manager, or you
can go to this link here, which
will be available in the slides
later on.
With that, I'll hand things
back to Noah to close us out.
NOAH FALSTEIN: Great.
Thank you very much, Ben.
[APPLAUSE]
I just want to
remind you to give us
your feedback, ways that we
can improve these sessions.
If we don't hear
from you, we don't
know what you're going to
want to know more about.
We've got just a few
minutes left here.
If people have any questions,
we've get some microphones
in the center aisle.
So please feel free to line up.
We've got time for, I think,
just one or two more questions.
And then we should
be able to go.
And I'm sure, come
on, some of you
have to have at least
a few questions.
All right.
Some of these brave
souls coming up here.
SPEAKER: Willing victims.
AUDIENCE: How does
Cast and Google TV
play nicely with each other?
Because it seems
like you can have
a game which is
broadcasting the Cast,
or you could have
a smart TV and have
your game running on the TV.
So how does that interaction
work between the two of them?
NATHAN CAMARILLO: That's
a really good question.
Everybody at home
heard that, too.
I'm sure I don't need
to repeat the question.
So the nice thing is, if
you're an Android developer
and you're really familiar and
comfortable with developing
native Android apps, Android
TV is a great platform for you
to develop for.
Cast is also a very
good option for you
to develop and
create your games.
Every Android TV is also
a Google Cast endpoint.
So the great thing is, as
phones and TVs get more and more
powerful, the Android TV
set-top box that you buy now
becomes a really powerful
device for Cast content
into the future.
AUDIENCE: So the
pre-registration thing
is a great thing for
business-- getting
users up-front is fantastic.
You don't have to
worry that much about
growth in the early stages.
But the problem
is is there a way
to use something like the staged
rollout or the beta release
along with this
pre-registrations
that you ensure that when
five million people install
your game on the first day you
don't have a 50% crash rate?
BENJAMIN FRENKEL:
The answer is, yes.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
NOAH FALSTEIN: That's
good and succinct.
Well, we're just
about out of time.
It looks like you're
out of questions.
So thank you very
much for coming
and enjoy tomorrow at I/O.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]